en este vídeo veremos la estéreo química
del bien o filo pero primero veamos un
repaso rápido de la reacción de piel
salde del lado izquierdo aquí tenemos al
lleno y del lado derecho
este es el día en off y lo sabemos que
la reacción de piel salde consiste en el
movimiento concertado de 6 electrones
peak así que estos electrones se mueven
hacia acá para formar un enlace estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá para
formar otro enlace y estos electrones py
se mueven claro hacia abajo así es cómo
obtenemos este producto
ahora los electrones en rojo formaron
este enlace los electrones piqué los
pondré en azul formaron este enlace y
finalmente los electrones vi en rosa
corresponden a estos electrones entonces
pensemos en la estéreo química del bien
o filo ya dijimos que este es nuestro
bien o filo y observen que los dos
grupos cr se encuentran cis respecto al
otro es decir que están del mismo lado
pero qué ocurre con el producto en
términos de exterior química cuando
tenemos dos grupos ser bueno aquí
tenemos una fotografía del bien y el
bien o phil arriba tenemos alguien que
se encuentra en un plano y abajo tenemos
al bien o filo que se encuentra en otro
plano los grupos cr son las esferas de
color rojo y miren cuando el bien y el
bien o si lo se acerca
sabemos que se forma un enlace entre
este carbono y este carbón aquí se forma
un enlace y otro enlace se forma entre
este carbono y este carbono aquí se
forma otro enlace pero observen qué
sucede cuando obtenemos el producto en
el inof y lo este carbono que tenía una
hibridación sp2 ahora tiene una
hibridación
sp3 y lo mismo ocurre con este carbono
que pasa de s&p 2 a esp 3 cambia su
hibridación entonces analicemos los
grupos ser como tenemos un movimiento
concertado de electrones observen que
estos grupos se re terminan del mismo
lado y si observamos el anillo de ciclo
externo desde
esta perspectiva lo que vemos es que
estos hidrógenos están lejos de nosotros
y los grupos cr están cerca de nosotros
entonces cuando dibujamos el ciclo
externo hay que poner los grupos cr
hacia nosotros
regresemos a lo que tenemos del lado
izquierdo y pensemos en la estéreo
química voy a dibujar los hidrógenos y
voy a poner una línea para que podamos
identificar a los grupos de la derecha
de los de la izquierda entonces si el
día no se acerca al yen o filo de esta
manera observen que los grupos cr se
encuentran del lado derecho y en el
producto terminan hacia nosotros por eso
están dibujados con estas cuñas entonces
lo que se encuentre del lado derecho de
la línea termina con una cuña y observen
que los grupos ser en el al que no se
quedan en la posición 6 es decir se
encuentran del mismo lado y lo que
tenemos del lado izquierdo de la línea
que en este caso tenemos hidrógenos pues
terminan hacia abajo en el producto aquí
tenemos los dos hidrógenos y observen
que están hacia abajo
así que los podríamos representar con
líneas punteadas ahora qué pasa si el
lino filo se acerca al yen o de otra
manera bueno en este caso si pensamos en
el doble enlace observen que los dos
grupos r se encuentran del lado
izquierdo voy a resaltar los así podemos
ver que los grupos r en el modelo
molecular corresponden a estos de aquí y
del lado derecho del doble enlace
tenemos dos hidrógenos que corresponden
a estos hidrógenos del modelo y ya
sabemos que se forma un enlace entre
este carbono y este y también se forma
otro enlace entre este carbono y este
entonces si analizamos el producto aquí
tenemos los dos enlaces que se formaron
y podemos ver que los grupos seres se
encuentran del mismo lado
si observamos la molécula desde esta
perspectiva lo que vemos es el anillo de
ciclo externo
y estos dos grupos se re quedan lejos de
nosotros así que los podemos representar
con líneas punteadas ahí está entonces
si regresamos a nuestro 10 no filo
acuérdense lo que tengamos del lado
izquierdo del doble enlace que en este
caso son los grupos r terminen hacia
abajo mientras que todo lo que se
encuentra del lado derecho que en este
caso claro son los hidrógenos terminen
hacia arriba se encuentren hacia arriba
respecto al plan y en nuestro producto
los representaría mos con una cuña pero
por otro lado si estos grupos se re son
iguales no importa mucho como los
representemos en el producto vamos a ver
un ejemplo sobre eso
vamos a dibujar el producto para esta
reacción de ti el saldo
sabemos que estos electrones se mueven
hacia acá formando un enlace entre estos
dos carbonos también estos electrones se
mueven hacia acá y estos electrones se
mueven hacia abajo
así que obtenemos un anillo de ciclo exc
no vamos a dibujarlo
y ahora qué les parece si pensamos en la
estéreo química del vino fil sabemos que
la conformación es cis así que
necesitamos tener a los dos grupos del
mismo lado del anillo y para eso podemos
usar cuñas o líneas punteadas yo voy a
usar dos cuñas aquí tenemos un esther y
aquí tenemos otro este éste es nuestro
producto
qué pasa si tenemos dos grupos cr en
posición trans respecto al otro bueno
voy a dibujar una línea observen que el
grupo de la izquierda está cerca del 10
así que en el modelo molecular
corresponde a este grupo r y el que se
encuentra del lado derecho y están lejos
del yen
así que corresponde a este grupo ahora
sabemos que se forma un enlace entre
estos dos carbonos y se forma otro
enlace entre estos dos así obtenemos
este producto donde estos son los
enlaces que se formaron entonces si
observamos la molécula desde esta
perspectiva lo que vemos es el ciclo
excel vamos a dibujarlo ahí está y
después este grupo r se encuentra lejos
de nosotros corresponde a este grupo r
que sería el grupo r de la izquierda así
que nuestro producto lo vamos a
representar con una
línea punteada y observen que este grupo
r se encuentra hacia nosotros y
corresponde a este grupo que está lejos
del lleno miren es el grupo r del lado
derecho entonces como se encuentra hacia
nosotros vamos a representarlo con una
cuña aquí tenemos el otro grupo r ahora
qué pasa si el bien o filo se acerca al
bien o de otra forma bueno vamos a
dibujar nuestra línea el grupo r del
lado izquierdo está más cerca del yen y
corresponde a este grupo mientras que
este grupo está más lejos del lleno así
que debe de ser este grupo y luego
sabemos que se forma un enlace entre
estos dos carbonos y se forma otro
enlace entre estos dos carbonos así que
en el producto corresponden a estos
enlaces y también tenemos un doble
enlace aunque por ahora no nos interesa
entonces si observamos la molécula
desde esta perspectiva podemos ver al
ciclo externo ahí está y también podemos
ver que este grupo r se encuentra lejos
de nosotros y corresponde a este grupo
el que se encuentra cerca del bien así
que al grupo r de la izquierda lo vamos
a representar con una línea punteada y
ahora este grupo r se encuentra hacia
nosotros corresponde a este grupo que
está lejos del bien
miren está del lado derecho así que lo
podemos representar con una cuña y vamos
a suponer que tenemos dos grupos r
iguales así que estas dos moléculas son
enantiómero si tenemos un par de
enantiómero en esta reacción digamos que
nos dan esta reacción de ti el saldo en
un examen
vamos a ver del lado izquierdo tenemos
al bien y del lado derecho tenemos al
lleno filo sabemos que se forma un
enlace
estos dos carbonos y también se forma
uno entre estos dos así que podemos
empezar pues dibujando nuestro anillo de
ciclo externo ahí está y ahora vamos a
pensar en la estéreo química del bien
off y si dibujamos nuestra línea
recuerde todo lo que tengamos del lado
derecho lo vamos a representar con una
cuña voy a dibujarla aquí tenemos un
externo hacia nosotros y luego todo lo
que tengamos del lado izquierdo del
doble enlace lo podemos representar con
una línea punteada porque está lejos de
nosotros voy a dibujar ahí está entonces
por el ejemplo anterior
ya sabemos que obtenemos un enantiómero
así que como nuestros productos
obtenemos este compuesto más su
enantiómero